so this is pretty much going to be the
question of the weekend what's funny or
Arthur or your highness and luckily I'm
there for you guys Arthur so Russell
Brand plays Arthur a really spoiled
filthy rich manchild which is pretty
much what he plays in every movie who
has to marry Jennifer Garner otherwise
he's gonna lose his entire inheritance
and I know what you're thinking he has
to marry Jennifer Garner so he can
remain filthy rich is there a downside
to the guy's life which is the funny
thing about Arthur because you actually
feel bad for him being in this
predicament which is not an easy thing
to do when the bad situation for the
main character is your ideal situation
but Russell Brand actually pulls it off
even though he plays the same character
he always plays in fact the one time he
didn't play a spoiled manchild was
hopped and even and he kind of did but I
didn't like the movies up there that is
now to my surprise I really liked Arthur
there wasn't too much that was special
about the movie but there's more good
about the movie than you think there
should be and for some messed up reason
it's just liberating to see people piss
away money like Arthur does I don't know
why because I would do that stuff in the
movie he's just doing [ __ ] I'm like
yeah I'd do that if I were that rich I'd
do that if I were that rich I would
definitely do that if I were that rich
I'd buy a Batmobile only not the Batman
Forever Batmobile you always go Tim
Burton Batmobile are the one that can
crawl on rooftops but at Schumacher
Batmobiles now now Arthur does a really
good job at showing you that money
doesn't buy happiness the guy's not
happy he has everything and he's not
happy the one thing that makes him happy
is this other girl that's not Jennifer
Garner who I am pretty sure is the lost
sister of Katee Sackhoff from Battlestar
Galactica who said my name once Jeremy
Jones I'm just saying she said my name
was awesome she was really good in the
movie too she was just a really normal
chick I liked seeing that even though he
did win her over by doing [ __ ] that only
really rich people can do he puts heart
behind it now the one that steals the
show for me is Helen Mirren she was the
best she's his nanny she puts up with
all of his [ __ ] she keeps him safe and
she's just awesomely sarcastic that's
what he needs he needs a chick like that
who's a little younger by a couple
months maybe I'm sure she's got it going
on I'm just saying now how funny was
Arthur it was pretty funny and it had
heart that's what really won me over on
it a movie can be funny and that's all
well and good but when he has heart for
some odd reason gets it a couple more
points and Arthur does it well even
though it has like an eight percent on
Rotten - me
don't listen to Rotten Tomatoes this
weekend yeah Arthur's not like this
original masterpiece of work but the
movie works and it made me like Russell
Brand a lot more even though he gets
that every night now I hate him again
Katy Perry's pretty hot even though
everything she says makes me want to
punch her I don't know why this the
sound of her voice so I would say Arthur
is a good time no alcohol required if
you don't mind watching a comedy with
heart that's not like some modern art
masterpiece of original work it's
actually pretty good but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]